i have a question for the guys so
out of your friends that maybe had a
whole face like slept around for a while
and then stopped
could they actually
be different long term actually
you guys are pretty young so i guess the
best question this is for sarah long
term does the guy actually stop because
to me it's like your habits are who you
are so if a dude spent 10 years sleeping
around what are the odds he can remain
faithful to because it depends on his
nature okay go ahead so
um
i can only go by my nature right
my nature is
i've been in three long-term
relationships
seven years
two and a half years and then ten years
right so
what's that what that's showing me is
that my nature is to be with a companion
right
but there are some men who have never
been in like any long-term relationship
you know what i mean and so their nature
is to just
have sex with whatever they can have sex
with so i think it depends on the man's
nature and i think
even when i can i can hold my hand up a
bit like even when i was in long-term
relationships i would i'd looked at
women thinking
and i had the chance right to do it and
i was like nah nah i can't but
that resides in all men yeah i think i
think that urge resides in all men
doesn't matter whether your nature is to
be with one person or i think that
nature to have animals as well yeah yeah
i think that nature
a man can have sex with more than one
person i think it resides i think that
if i think that if women really
uh respected
the sacrifice it took it actually takes
a man to
to um
to go to to
stray away from his nature and focus
solely on him then maybe it'll be a lot
easier to to to do that because there's
she she understands like wholeheartedly
that is that is a
you're going against your nature as a
human
to to to to remain here does that make
sense i don't think this is a male
nature is respected as much as female
nature like for instance
like
we we always talk about when a woman's
on her period and what and what
you know hormonal changes and what we
must do and how we must be sensitive and
stuff like that but when we're talking
about a male nature it's almost like
well you can't you can't but you can't
just keep it in your in your pack
it's almost like
you're marginalizing our our
our expression our nature as men do you
know what i mean at the end of the day
and it's uh and it's as you said it's
only been recent times when this is
uh
like it hasn't been monogamy is very
recent yeah since it is yeah recent
questions
so for the majority of history we've
been
we've been
kind of
able to to spread our seed a little bit
a little bit wider do you know what i
mean so i have another question have you
ever been in a relationship where the
girl turns you down for sex and is it
frustrating when you're trying to be
monogamous with her and yet she won't
say yes to sex
see that doesn't that that's what
doesn't make sense to me like that like
how can you if you're the person who's
supposed to be
uh keeping me monogamous
why would you deny it why would you deny
the the
sometimes that's the trap because they
want you to go elsewhere
do you think yeah nothing's just
self-entitled you reckon
some girls settle with guys yeah i agree
with you so i think some girls try to
get like guys to cheat or get them to
like
they'll pick fights so they don't
because a lot of girls are
non-confrontational so they don't want
to be the one to dump you so they'll try
to they'll try to like argue with you
until you dump them or like make your
life hell until you dump them well
patrice o'neill said
generally women
want to know a man can fish
right
and if he's caught her as a fish
the reason why she was attracted to him
is because he was officially
and the minute you show them your woman
that you're no longer able to fish
she doesn't really like you anymore
you see the thing is the the time that
that happened to me is kind of different
to those stories
[Music]
it was going down right fine
cool speaking of the mic yeah sex was
being withheld it was going down
whatever she cheats on me with this guy
fine what
do you mean fine emotionally or
she did what she did when i say fine i'm
just saying it's like it's what it is
it's like walk through yeah i'm fine i'm
over there i'm over that now i'm fine
cool so then she she moves from him to
this girl comes out as gay
and is now engaged to this girl oh
yeah but she still banged the guy though